good morning John I'm headed out on tour
next week so expect some travel vlogging
all the shows are all ages and tickets
are around 20 dollars and somebody asked
me on tumblr what is the difference
between Hank green and Hank green and
the perfect strangers it's pretty simple
it's more fun to play music with a band
and I think it's more fun to listen to
music with a band and so some of my
friends got together and we made a band
we play the same old Hank green songs
you'll hear deathly hallows an
anglerfish and strange jared also some
newer songs like I love science and oh
JK Rowling and we are all bad people and
even some songs that we have never
before performed live together like
we're all gonna die which is a song I
recently released and also this song
right here surprise new song and he's
been anything long enough now she knows
what she will and she won't sometimes
she's gonna be up when you're - gonna
know things that you've done and a lot
of the world isn't here just be you
Danny being Annie doesn't make you less
you she's got her own baggage she
doesn't need you to
and he doesn't meet your luck Danny
doesn't meet your worry and Annie
doesn't hate your guts but she just need
you to get up and get out of the way do
you ever think you're holding hood down
- you ever even think to ask why if you
have friend I stuck on the ground are
you terrified that you can fly you maybe
it's time you take a look at yourself
and he's not a trophy you can keep on
your shelf is pulling you through life
you put north
Oh Annie doesn't meet your luck Annie
doesn't need your worry and Annie
doesn't hit your guts but she just can
do to get up and get out of the way I
have to ask as a friend friend to both
of you so when you hold her close and
keep her near is that love or is it fear
I have to ask because you have to know
you're all they get to keep her if you
let her go I'll let her go let her go
let her go
Annie doesn't need your luck nanny
doesn't lead you're worried and Annie
doesn't hate your guts but she does need
you to get up and get out of her way
yeah Oh get up and get out of her way
boy get up and get out of the way get up
and get out of her way getting ready to
go on to her has involved lots of work
I've been quite tired and recently I got
home from work and I grabbed some peanut
M&Ms which my favorite and I went and I
laid down on my couch so I wake up a
half hour later and in my mouth is a
half-eaten M&M it was a weird sensation
and flavor but I ate it and that's the
whole story I just wanted to tell you
that one so we have been having some
trouble selling as many tickets as we
would like to on tour this is kind of
strange because like when Kansas we're
doing amazing but in Los Angeles where
there are more people than Kansas we're
doing that as well so if you are in
Austin San Diego Los Angeles Anaheim or
San Francisco and you're considering
maybe coming to the show consider it
hard I'm super excited about it I hope
you will be too up for me
concerts have always been something that
causes me a lot of anxiety like going to
shows always freaked me out but also
those shows are some of my most precious
memories and we strive to be that for
the people that come to our show and
there's one thing that always kind of
bugs me about concerts is I would I go I
kind of want to know as many of the
songs as I can because it's more fun if
I'm like singing along having a good
time but you never know what they're
gonna play so I've put together a
limited but not complete set list of
some of the songs we're going to be
playing if you would like to know what
those are in advance as part of my
general strategy to get rid of this
conception that you have to be the
smartest most knowledgeable person who
knows everything about the band and the
act no just have a good time it's not
about looking cool and that's it coming
to you straight from the mouth that once
had an Eminem in it for a whole half an
hour John I'll see you on Tuesday